this morning we're hearing from people
who knew the suspect in the University
of Idaho killings Brian coburger is
charged with four counts of first-degree
murder he is due in court today but is
not expected to enter a plea coburger is
a graduate student at nearby Washington
State University Lilia Luciano spoke to
two of his neighbors
I try to remember everything that I can
but nothing seemed out of the ordinary
in an exclusive interview one of Brian
coburger's Neighbors in Pullman
Washington told us the suspected killer
spoke to him about the murders the
neighbor asked not to be identified he
brought it up in conversation asked if I
had heard about the murders and which I
did and then he said yeah it seems like
they have no leads it seems like it was
a crime of passion in one previous
conversation he said coburger asked him
if he'd be able to kill someone as a
member of the military another time the
neighbor told us he'd mentioned watching
Netflix's drama series about Jeffrey
Dahmer allegedly prompting co-burger to
share how rare serial killers are he had
a very kind and good side to him we also
spoke to another neighbor of coburgers
who said they talked to each other about
their grad school research coburger was
pursuing a PhD in criminology he
mentioned he likes to study about the
role of police and he I think told me
that he wants to work with them
investigators have not yet released the
motive for co-burger or a connection to
the victims but his court proceedings
get underway one piece of evidence that
may connect him to the crime is a knife
sheath like this one founded the murder
scene this is a strong case because of
the knife Chief CBS News legal analyst
Ricky cleeman says if that link is
proved in court the knife sheath places
him physically in the house at some
point in time but not necessarily on the
night of the killings that is going to
be what the defense is going to try to
show through cross-examination or their
own experts but that's a real stretch
as has been a case of with this case
there are more questions than answers we
learned also this week that a judge
sealed the search warrant for Brian
coburger's apartment citing public
safety concerns and saying that the
details could prematurely end the
investigation we of course asked Ricky
Clement about this she says without
those details we won't know why but it
could have been done to preserve
evidence and protect Witnesses Gail yeah
Lilia the more you hear on this case the
more you want to know it's just still so
heartbreaking thank you